you break down barriers like this a
handshake and a smile you know many of
them in in the Hollywood Canon with
Bollywood coming into the team but they
are free to come out why cause the
creator of the world and the creator of
human beings he did not create us to get
sick and that's why he commanded us to
eat that which is good and that which is
good has to be forgiven
Helen has to be funny the canal is not
why you don't eat it
as-salaam-alaikum parents were here in
Colorado Aviva's show you you just says
something interesting you met you were
mentioning all these different countries
yeah I was living a stand how you doing
Stan pretty good how do you feel
visiting the mosque oh I love it here
man I like the people I like the
knowledge he's actually our next door
neighbor
we're trying to get more people to visit
us to connect with us to make this human
connection what would you say to the
world is it a good idea I mean people
many people are scared you know what I
mean but what message would you have for
them break down barriers like this a
handshake and a smile thank you coming
all the way from Chicago you know from
the cold out there you heard that
message guys come and make the human
connection visit the Muslims in the MOG
well you got to be scared of live
I was very touched yesterday when we had
David I think he's a pastor he's coming
tonight too and he and what he said it
really hit home he said he was actually
scared you know to me because a lot of
the programming conditioning that's
going on people you know listen to the
media and they have all these false
notions and impression about Muslims but
then when he came and sat with us just
like you had his told you change well
that is how you break it down the smile
I'm staying
tell me more about yourself you got to
do that on your own
thank you so what you said we said
American she was commenting on his
church and I was telling him that we
have so much diversity here that out of
you know this world basically and I just
counted physically brother move afar
from India your father of course from
Bosnia brother Sammy from Algeria
Chekov nasha from Ghana brother arrival
from Pakistan from Ghana Ghana myself
from Egypt
brother tell me is from Indonesia
brother Abdel half of from Palestine
brother Omar not from Jordan oh man from
Sultanate oh man imagine this and that's
already over half a dozen closed about
it you know I almost got you not UN here
yeah
but you know like robbing a limo
what's not cool about Malaika is the
harley-davidson Muslim start a Muslim
Salam aleikum Somalia the Akuma Salam
what I want to lay over the catch is
that we'll have a travel to Denver thank
you for having me so we're having
breakfast with our family here in Denver
Colorado's down follow this is a bro
that I'm real of shows the best show in
sha allah as far as learning islam and
knowing what you want to do about your
life why we love brother ID and welcome
anytime sha na na
thank you very much from Varna
how are you exam from then I'm from
Ghana where I'm flattered from you to
cry from weird I'm flattered from Pluto
you know you look I'm flattered rank and
plant oh yeah I'm from Pluto where's
that that's a city in gun oh that's the
City of God yeah masha'Allah I'm kidding
you know your brother man your brother
from Ghana
you know fili boy with New York swagger
you know you ask Allah so had no talent
to bless you and bless your family you
gotta shake Eddie with us
inshallah today after selected but do
you have a good breakfast butter the
lovely but you mentioned that there's a
lot a lot of people who are coming to
Islam but they're scared to come out
they're scared because of the winning
team exactly
you know many of them in in the
Hollywood cannon would Bollywood coming
into the deal but they are afraid to
come out why because they've seen that
wherever Muslims are mentioned is sort
of like problems of legend
Time Lords so they may wanna pleasing
the seats in the Hollywood so they'd
rather keep it between the men and the
law between them and they Creator until
they get you know grounded to see what
the Muslims will come out of that box
out of that box
so until Muslims we are together
collectively come and buy dignity for
our own faith it's not gonna work the
way we move today with classical
knowledge unless we make it relevant to
the people people can get connected
Islam solving the problems Islam is some
giving them solutions to their daily you
know problem if not those people who
remain hidden in the Hollywood just like
some so have ur
well hidden I would be freak so those in
Hollywood impressing Islam and keeping
it low low we can't blame you
we can't blame you why because the habit
went through the same so maybe we're
going through the same you know until
things get you know better with each
other so some of them they conceal
defeat until a 103 to 106 were were
revealed in sera tea and not each of the
16 that those who say publicly that they
disbelieve in Allah but even though in
their hearts they have the belief of
Allah so those in Hollywood those in
candy wood those in Bollywood so long as
you are a man serving one God even if
you are from what we call it you from
Bob Marley's family or tribe smoking
weed three times a day and all that
smoking we cannot take away your faith
between you know God and also doing some
you know bad things does not mean you
cannot be a believer believing in God
believes it's in your heart so keep it
and stop building on it and always if
you want to be successful try your best
between you and Allah try your best try
your best at least 3 a.m. 4 a.m. wake up
whatever you doing in the world that is
wrong that you cannot stop right away
that you cannot stop right away to be
practical we cannot tell you quit right
away because you can do it so how about
did not quit right away the ayats came
to build them gradually to quit so you
know if let's say if you smoke cigarette
maybe you smoke like 2 or 3 packs a day
we say you know what just cut it to 2
and the hours that you're supposed to
spend in the last one just reserve it
like 3 a.m. ask Allah to guide you to
come out of it completely and then later
on you may quit instead of to go 1 you
know later on you're quitting sound off
you know 1 pack you may go to cigarettes
a day and that's how you cut it but if
you want to cut the you know one shot
you may cut it but few weeks later you
will return back to it because it's not
fractured so it gradually come out of
whatever you into it
and make sure you make Quran in the
morning 3 a.m. 4 a.m. that's when
almighty your Creator and mine asking it
who wants down I'm right here to help
who wants to be forgiven I'm here to
forgive who once exists I'm here to
bring you will be grounded in shadows
are usually if you comment on this I
usually leave people with homework
people who are you know intelligent
they're searching for why am I here why
have I been creative what's my purpose
it's a long hadith but and the last part
where the crater's saying all of my
slaves are misguided unless my guide
that he asked me of my guidance with
laws why leave people with that simple
homework asked the Creator oh boy oh boy
oh boy I tell you what the hadith the
hadith i Doan says the super-heavyweight
happy is beyond that this is hadith of
museum prophets no Salim said as Imam
Muslim reported that cool nukem balloon
in lemon had a tree buddy
all my servants all of you are misguided
all of us no no in no exception those in
Egypt those in Saudi dosimeter needles
in Africa those in Asia does in America
as here in America in Denver Colorado
and every single soul or every single
person is misguided period who are
guided those whom Almighty Allah guided
so ask me for guidance
I will guide you so whatever you don't
mom don't don't worry about what people
say about you worry about that happy
that everybody is God is misguided
except those whom Almighty Allah has
guided so ask me forgot it I will guide
you so your homework
that she will take go home tonight and
professor Sodom imagine shame Prophet
himself used to ask Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala to keep him up on the back so if
profitable as to be kept upon the path
is there any energy
not at all see in the hadith along with
a semi-wet full of the animal
overshadowed by a very polemic kind of
here telephone dinner the most beautiful
female have to the evening guide me the
portion that I want a point guide me and
take me out of the schism or our being
arguments that just leaves me found
themselves in take me out and guide me
and do not look do not allow me to get
caught in problems get caught in
arguments report in division get caught
in schism guide me and take me out
if you prophet had made it and this is
an opportunity for Fiji middle up to be
ethnic memorize this a distinction had
come to you with this
memorize it a de Lima to leaf a Fiji
mineral have to be evening again if any
the mustard leaf affinity mineral
Huckabee evening that's the homework of
the day last thing I want to ask you
because obviously Islam is a complete
way of life and nothing is left out so
we talked about the spiritual now the
physical the beautiful ayah and Islam
has all the solutions nowadays chronic
diseases are skyrocketing cancer one out
of two men are expected to have cancer
one other three women eight ninety five
percent of the chronic diseases are
related to the food choices the food
choices that we are making in there's a
beautiful ayah in the Quran all of them
are beautiful one I want to share with
you is in Chapter two
172 or the crater Allah so Allah is
saying yeah a you Hannah Dena are
Minooka lumen
died a bad team arrows
look Allah is saying o you who believe
eat of the good food to eat in that I
have provided you and be grateful what
can we take on it when Allah is talking
about your ribs
the real food the food now that is this
food like nowadays we sent a lot of fake
food that's getting people sick and that
so what's your input on this one all
those number the tiny bag the real food
good food wise all I'll mention this
okay because the creator of the world
and the creator of human beings he did
not create us to get sick and that's why
he commanded us to eat that which is
good and that which is good has to be
forgiven
Helen has to be PEP canal is not pie you
don't eat it coke may be higher but it's
not funny for your system so don't don't
drink it you know Sodor in general may
be halal they hella I did not believe
for you sugar is bad but it's not pie
for you sugar as what I learned from dr.
Oman you know because this des is filled
you know dr. Homer can tell tell him you
know more about this sugar thickens the
blood and once the blood is taken
you cannot process the memory is not
processed in world and the bad is not
responding so the first that you talk
about verse number 117 rat before it 168
and I called in my hand kind because in
172 that you mention to 174 and the
called upon the believers un animun
but the one before in one since the
eighty called man come here are you a
new member fill of the halal employee
but when at the table with water [ __ ] on
all mankind he form that which allah
subhanho wa taala had made panel and
play it for you and do not follow the
party nor the path of Shaitaan path of
shaitan is to get you to think like okay
senses and then let me go ahead and
consume it and you get sick and
did you go to the hospital the doctor
however nice he or she maybe they do not
care about you as they care about their
checks that they will get at the end of
the month so whatever they have to
prescribe for you to come back and get
medicine and keep on going to ride it
CBS or on Walgreen to be getting
medicine back and forth so that the
check can keep on flowing and the
Keystone will keep on getting the only
insurance money and all that that's what
the doctor cares about them for the most
part except few of them and very few so
I'm not ordered to giving you the chill
and prevention is better than cure as
they say do not even get there before
you require go into the hospital they
will pay him said I spend more than
forty years of never taking any medicine
more no crying more than 40 years not no
medicine he said nothing I just
if nugget haddock is just root clear
with Fatah over why a person may think
they see maybe super shake like he
delivered angels and all that that's why
and maybe he is so knowledgeable that's
why no it's not about that it's about
what goes in his mouth to get to
estimate that's what gets people sick
what goes in the mouth and gets to your
system that's what gets people sick what
you breathe is what gets you sakes for
environment to be clean Muslims around
the world for the most part we go to the
Masjid the bathroom is not clean that's
not the deal block of our Deen so to
sort of be our bathroom clean when we
have restaurants Irishman's in the
bathrooms supposed to be super clean I
mean that's the teachings of the Deen
the bathrooms supposed to be cleaner
than even the office of the president
might because that's where people go and
you know release themselves and it's um
release themselves and if it's dirty
they're gonna get sick so instead of you
know going to the hospital for
prescription and all that prevents
yourself and that's the reason why
prevention is better than cure cure and
heal yourself with black seed oil but
black seed itself so if you get black
seed oil or black seed in the original
world and you get some them you know
together if you say
you have cold you know you have honey
you mix it with warm water and you drink
it change a warm water and drink it this
are the natural remedies that people are
not teaching German as one of the top
chappathis that one could actually get
involved and professors and embedded as
through a hadith that we've heard and
also coconut oil coconut oil and learned
from dr. Bob Solow that coconut oil what
is even better than coconut oil is the
coconut water it's medicine drinking it
and taking it but all the fast food
canned food processed food are not good
for us and that's what we call it the
fake food so a boy we and we have the
statement avoid fake food eat real food
the real food is that tight about
exactly
many people conflate they confuse sugar
in the date we warn the Apple there's
sugar in there but it's with the fiber
it's a real food we're talking about the
the processed fake we're fine that's
something totally different that's what
we're talking exactly yeah but the real
fool when you got because many people
get confused to say well sugars in the
day no that's that well then it's a
whole food it's a real food you see the
good thing about what you just mentioned
caught talking about the sugar in the
day know what is in the bit is not sugar
that's because what the body needs is
not yes body made sugar you know human
beings bad without sugar he or she may
get sick and die eventually so the sugar
that your body needs is not the sugar or
brown sugar that we consume or take is
not the sugar that's your body meat is
the natural sugar the sugar that is
found is found in in dates is found in
norm when we eat bananas bananas bananas
oranges this are actually her al-qaeda
but because they contain the sugar that
body needs so this sugar even though we
call them sugar because they sweet but
they are mushy that has the glucose that
human beings body needs so if you want
more of this you know dr. Ahmadi even
some herbs together for Muslim world and
non-muslim world where's it where's the
Sheikh Omar that utopia you know dr.
Hamid is in New York is well when it
comes to and he said adaptable
profession and well and grounded and the
same time akka hadn't off any doctor in
America who had combined you know
natural medicine wealth today zero War
medicine would to burnable at dr. Ouma
as of today so people check him up and
get him assess you and through you know
and healthy Institute you can go to
dividual back and here's al h AI r z dot
org and just send a message to you thank
you for sharing those